Hey everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
Um,
I'm [inaudible],
I work on Google translate today.
We have a very special guest Dr. Douglas Fields.
He is a neuroscientist and an international authority on brain development,
Neuroglia interactions and the cellular mechanisms of memory.
He is currently chief of nervous system development and plasticity section at
the National Institutes of health.
And she is the author of many magazine articles and books including why we snap,
which you can grab in the back if you haven't yet.
And like we're were going to have a quick book signing and his other book is the
other brain.
Please give a warm welcome to Dr [inaudible].
[inaudible].
Thank you very much.
Thank you all for coming.
It's a delight to be here.
Um,
so I've been given the rare opportunity to talk about two books in one hour.
normally either one of these subjects would take a whole hour.
So I apologize.
I'm going to go really quick and I'm going to only be able to hit the high
points.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
I realize here at Google,
you're,
you're a CPS or over clocked and you'll be able to do this,
but,
um,
we'll get through it.
And the first talk is,
uh,
related to,
the subject of snapping.
Um,
so this is a very interesting topic that I think touches everyone.
And one way or another,
um,
many people want to admit it,
but everyone admits they know somebody else who has issues.
And snapping is bewildering because it's this unconscious aggressive impulse
that's triggered by something in the environment.
And it's not conscious.
It's not deliberate.
Why break a dish?
Why smash a tennis racket?
Why get into v vehicular jousting on the freeway and,
and wreck your car or worse,
it doesn't make any sense.
So that's what snapping is this,
this,
and that's what's disturbing about it is that it's not conscious.
It's rapid triggered by something in the environment and the behavior is
incorrect.
Right?
Um,
it's followed by regret.
Uh,
so it's kind of embarrassing.
It,
if it's appropriate behavior,
we call it,
we don't call it snapping,
we call it quick thinking or something like that.
Um,
so it is interesting because this covers an unconscious part of the brain that
we're talking about.
Um,
and it seems to me that,
um,
this is a new subject but a very important and overlook subject.
When I read the newspapers every day,
we read about the violence and domestic disputes,
barroom brawls,
all these kinds of things.
And you know,
it's not mentally ill people mental illness,
people with mental illness do not commit violent acts anymore than anyone else.
Um,
and so we do understand how drugs can interfere with judgment,
but I think we're overlooking the big issues.
The majority of,
uh,
what we call snapping or violence that we read about every day is so called
normal people.
Um,
and I'd like to understand how,
how that works.
Um,
but it's actually broader than snapping when you get into the subject.
The book has more than that because it's talking about,
it involves the neurocircuitry of unconscious behaviors and threat detection.
What's different about this approach in the book is it's not a psychological
approach that you may be familiar with.
It's a neuroscience approach,
which we look at snapping as a behavior.
All behaviors are controlled by the brain.
Let's go into the brain and see what circuits mediate this behavior.
It's only been possible with new methods of neuroscience.
So that's,
that's the,
uh,
the new approach.
Um,
and also,
uh,
unconscious operation of the brain,
but also fear and whatnot.
So the point is we're all wired for violence.
We don't have to be taught violence.
Um,
all animals need to have this aggressive behavior in order to protect
themselves,
to protect their offspring.
Carnivals need to have aggressive behavior in order to,
uh,
capture food.
Um,
it's the circuits that carry this out or not in the conscious part of the brain.
They're in the unconscious part of the brain called the hypothalamus and other
circuitry.
And that's what I'd like to talk about is the circuitry of snapping.
So,
um,
and aggressive behavior.
We're all wired for violence.
And in order to give you an idea of what made me realize that I want to read a
snippet out of my book because this is what inspired me to try to understand,
uh,
it was an instance where I snapped and,
I wanted to realize if I could risk my life or limb in an incident and in
response to something in my environment.
I want to know how that works and not be consciously aware of it.
Okay.
So,
um,
after Paris we traveled to Barcelona for my next lecture at an international
meeting of neuroscientists.
The morning before the meeting began,
we made a quick visit to the Audi Cathedral is sending the steps out of the
dingy subway station smelling of concrete dust and sweat.
We emerged in the brilliant Barcelona son,
a crowd of passengers pressed upon us and a gray blurred.
So I was traveling to a neuroscience meeting and I brought my 17 year old
daughter with me.
That's very unusual.
Usually I travel alone,
so we thought we'd go see the Gaudi Cathedral before I give my lecture.
So we're coming up out of the subway system.
Suddenly I felt a sharp tug at my pant leg as if swatting a mosquito.
I slapped a zipper pocket,
but my left me Lee knee to my wallet was gone.
My left arm shot back blindly in a flash.
I closed line the robber as he pivoted to hand my wa while it off to his partner
and flea down the steps as if swinging a sledgehammer.
I hurled him by his neck over my left hip and slammed and belly first under the
pavement where I flattened into the ground and apply to headlock.
Displaying playing my legs for hip control like a wrestler pending an opponent I
yelled for help.
Right.
56 years old,
130 pounds.
Wire rimmed glasses gray here.
Um,
I have no martial arts training.
I have no military experience,
no background in street fighting,
drawing on junior high school wrestling moves.
40 years ago I found myself applying an illegal chokehold.
The streets smarts hoodlum struggling in my arms was in his late twenties,
early thirties.
Police.
I shouted.
Call the police.
I've got him.
Well,
there was no reply,
no gasps of shock from the dense crowd.
No one was coming to my aid.
Instead.
From my perspective on the ground,
all I saw were men's feet closing it around me in a tight circle.
They were all part of the gang oblivious to being hunted as pray.
We assumed that the crowd was the normal throng of passengers bumping a Jocelyn
through the Barcelona metro system.
The muscle man beneath me struggle to break my grip with his neck in the crook
of my left arm.
I synched with all the forests my biceps could produce cutting the blood off to
his brain and air into his lungs,
bending his head back.
I took his spine backward,
painfully tipping his face skyward,
his eyes and mouth open,
wide in shock pain and fear the wallet pop free as he tossed it toward his
accomplice and grass furiously at my arm to break my strength.
That's my wallet.
I yelled,
I woman's hand shot between the thicket of legs.
Instantly I recognized it is my daughter's.
She had been cut off by the gang that had encircled and trapped us and circling
me silently like a pack of wolves,
captain of the ultimate football Frisbee team.
Kelly dove through the air in an arc as if to deflect the disc inches from an
opponent's grasp in a full on layout on a solid concrete.
She intercepted the past and miss mid air and tip the wallet into the palm of my
outstretched right hand,
reading the eyes on accomplice,
fixating on my blackberry,
spinning on the pavement.
She lunged again and beat him to the prize.
With my wallet retrieved and realized that I was horribly outnumbered.
I released the thief and bounced to the balls of my feet as he scurried
backwards on his butt like an injured crab escaping crazy man.
He gasped looking into the eyes of the half dozen muscular thug surrounding me.
I tried to discern if he choked out those partly words to deflect suspicion or
if he meant it as a threat.
Now what a massive surge of adrenaline fueled my twitching muscles and nerves to
levels of raw power I had never felt before.
I was now struggling not to pick up the next hoodlum squaring off with me,
hoist him over my head and hurling into the accomplices,
knocking them all down steps to the metro station like bowling pins.
Now,
it wasn't a question of whether I could execute the superhuman feat.
I had no doubt that I could do it.
It was charged with adrenaline.
Rather,
I was trying not to do it simply because this might not be my mass move,
at least not yet.
Suddenly in middle age,
well dressed,
Spaniard,
stuck casually between me and the attackers and with flicking shoeing motions of
his fingers.
He said he know crazy.
Go now without breaking stride.
He descended the steps into the metro station.
As he passed me,
he smiled and said,
why no good go now in passing,
he had deflected the situation to its best possible outcome.
Uh,
draw the band of robbers scattered into the metro station like rats down a
sewer,
leaving my daughter and me standing there stunned my wallet clenched in a death
grip and my right hand.
Unfortunately that was not the end of it.
The gang pursued Kelly and me throughout the city for the next two hours.
There were not after my wallet anymore.
I had humiliated and beaten up a member of their gang.
They wanted revenge.
I tried every trick to elude them fleeing into tourist shops and through noisy
restaurants,
cutting through back alleys,
abruptly crossing streets to reverse course changing clothing and when they got
too close,
leaving the sidewalk and running down the center of the boulevard,
weaving through oncoming cars.
At one point we stopped traffic to jump into a taxi in the middle of a three
lane boulevard,
but they had cell phones and everywhere we went they sent increasingly menacing,
tattooed thugs with steroid bloated biceps to intercept us.
As we dodged the gang of robbers,
we witnessed them casually pick wallets from two more tourists.
I even snapped photographs of them doing it.
The stupid mistake is it turned out because the lookout on my side of the street
caught me doing it.
The unshaven goon came running up the sidewalk jabbering Russian into a cell
phone and extending a video camera and an unconvincing attempt to as a tourist.
We fled down the side street.
And as they closed in on us,
we are forced to jump into a taxi and escape to a small town,
an hour away in the cab.
My daughter asked in a tone filled with shock and disbelief,
where did you learn to do that?
I looked over and saw you swinging some guy around by the neck.
I couldn't figure out what was happening.
I laughed.
A nurse,
nervous relief,
170 euro cab fare.
Later we were broke but safe.
And now my daughter is convinced that my job at the National Institutes of
health is just a cover for my real job as a spy.
All right?
So I realized there I was on the ground and suddenly this thought bubbles up to
my head.
What the heck are you doing?
So the point is,
the neural circuitry involved in that behavior didn't involve my cerebral
cortex.
And that's because when you're faced with a sudden a threatening situation,
conscious deliberation is too slow.
Your conscious brain can't hold her,
um,
and it can hold enough information and operates too slowly.
So the brain's threat detection mechanism is subcortical unconscious.
Um,
and the wiring for this is,
uh,
in,
the Amygdala and in,
uh,
in the hypothalamus.
So as I was a wandering around with my daughter,
consciously engaged in where we're going to go,
my threatened the Pec detection mechanism was looking at threats.
And that's happening with all of you.
You're constantly happier,
huge part of your brain devoted to threat detection and on the lookout for
threats.
So all the sensory information before it goes to your cerebral cortex vision
sound goes to the center of your threat detection mechanism in the Amygdala.
That's why you can dodge a basket ball,
get it out of the way.
And then you go,
what was that?
That was visual information going to your Amygdala.
And then later it goes to your cerebral cortex,
but you've already acted.
So,
um,
in the early twenties,
Walter Hess,
a stuck electrodes into a cat brain and stimulate a different parts of the
brain.
And he found one part in the hypothalamus.
When he stimulated this,
the cat launched into an attack and would kill another animal in its cage.
So this area is called the hypothalamic attack area.
And uh,
this is true and other animals and humans have it as well.
So this,
the question is what feeds into this attack area to cause this violent response.
Um,
and the new information is showing that very discrete circuits feed into this
area in response to different threats.
Aggressive behavior is highly regulated.
You're not going to engage in aggression for anything but very except very
specific reasons because you're risking your life and limb.
So it's highly regulated now,
although it seems that anything could trigger aggression when you read the
paper.
In fact,
very few things can only nine different things.
And these evolved different circuits.
So,
um,
this has scientists have been able to do in recent years is used new methods up
to genetics and uh,
to genetic engineering.
So you can engineer neurons to release flashes of light when they fire stick a
fiber optic camera into a experimental animal,
haven't engaged in aggression and see which neurons light up.
And now you know,
the circuitry,
you can activate and inactivate specific neurons by shining a laser into the
brain.
And neurons that are genetically encoded to respond to that light by firing or
inhibiting.
So now you can turn on behaviors,
different aggressive behaviors.
What this line of research has shown is that very specific behaviors like
maternal aggression here familiar with Ralph,
familiar with maternal aggression.
If you threatened them,
others,
uh,
young,
then the mother will attack.
Um,
using these methods I've talked about,
you could see that circuitry,
you can activate those circuits with a laser and activate the mother to,
uh,
exhibit aggressive behavior against an intruder.
You can inactivate that and the mother will no longer protect her pups.
However,
she still will have aggressive responses to different kinds of threats.
So this has led to realizing that our threat detection mechanism,
unlike old idea of the lizard brain,
the primitive part of the brain,
cause you do Beasley things.
No,
we have very elaborate,
exquisite,
um,
uh,
neural circuitry to release aggression in response to specific triggers.
So,
um,
let me
tell you about the triggers.
And again,
these are based on neurocircuitry,
not on some classification.
And if you read the neuroscience,
behavioral physiologist and psychologist,
they all have different terminology.
For aggression,
different kinds of aggression.
I've dispensed with that.
And for two reasons,
I thought that would be helpful to understand the mechanisms to have in the
monic so that you could remember these nine circuits that will trigger
aggression.
And secondly,
this will also allow you to control the circuitry because in fact,
we have these circuits because we need them.
You don't want to prevent,
uh,
this response in the right circumstance.
You just want to prevent the misfires.
So if you can suddenly feel the sense of rage on the highway,
let's say,
um,
and understand which of these life more it's triggered,
the mnemonic I created was life marts,
then you can control the rage response because you'll realize it's a misfire and
the rage will subside.
So there's not gonna be time to go through all these triggers.
Um,
but I'll just quickly talk about some Elf for life and limb.
We've already talked about,
um,
you know,
uh,
defensive aggression.
If you're attacked,
you will fight back any animal will.
Um,
we also mentioned a maternal aggression.
That's the F in life.
Morts.
Um,
the trigger is environment.
Many animals are territorial.
And they will defend their territory aggressively and market fiercely defend
intrusion,
intruders,
uh,
primates and humans are,
are fiercely territorial.
Uh,
intruders will be shot.
Somebody enters your house on announced it's going to trigger an aggressive
response.
So that's the,
uh,
the trigger.
I'm just going to give you another example.
I can't go through them all.
T is for tribe.
Social animals use aggression to protect their group.
Many animals will have this.
Um,
and certainly human beings have this capability as well.
I mean,
the selective service system proves that we all have the capability for violence
and destruction to protect our country,
for example.
Um,
so that's the t for tried programming.
We need to realize that's also the key to our success.
That we can go shirts and skins and play at the maximum physical metal
capability of the human being on a basketball court.
Just arbitrarily divide into two teams.
This is what got us to the moon.
We compete with another country.
Um,
so this is really the key to our success as a species,
but it also leads to racism,
leads to wars.
It leads to gang violence.
Uh,
so those are two of the triggers that I want to mention.
Um,
and I just don't have time to go through them all,
but I want to give one,
make one more point.
We have these circuits and better than our brain because we have the same brain
we had a hundred thousand years ago when we lived in the plains of Africa and we
are fighting tooth and nail for fight,
for survival.
Same brain,
but we're now operating in an environment.
Our brain was never evolved to operate in completely different world.
So what happens is you get misfires triggered by situations in the modern world
that never existed.
Driving is a great example.
It hits almost all these triggers.
So I'll just give you one and it's the trigger.
So you're out on one oh one you're driving on the freeway,
somebody cuts in front of you.
Suddenly you're feeling enraged and some people will,
you know,
and in a gun battle or,
or a rack.
But we all,
many people will feel the sudden rage when somebody does that.
Why,
why,
why do we feel anger?
Why don't we feel some other emotion that's a misfire.
We perceive the area around our cars,
our territory.
Somebody intruded into our territory trip.
This trigger for us to defend it for the purpose of the activity.
We're involved in transportation.
It doesn't matter if the guy's on your front bumper,
your bat bumper.
It's a matter of a couple of seconds difference.
But it's this illusion that we're traveling with territory.
If you're running and having a foot race over the ground,
that never happens.
People are free to run ahead of you.
Somebody cuts in front of you and there's faster.
You might laugh,
you wouldn't get angry.
So,
um,
that's an example of,
of a misfire.
So the point is we have these circuits because we need them.
They exist because they're important to our survival.
Um,
and it's,
it's not,
uh,
you know,
it's not necessarily a disorder,
but a,
but a misfiring.
And I want to give an example again,
read a snippet out of the book.
Uh,
the demonstrates why we have these triggers.
Um,
it just say that many cases,
uh,
the same thing happens when you have a hero.
Will come to the aid of somebody and they say,
well,
what were you thinking when you did that?
And they say,
I didn't think I just reacted.
And afterwards they're shaking,
but they,
they were heroic.
So here's an example,
a snippet from the book.
Lucky.
What are you doing?
Get your butt up here.
Let's go.
Heather.
Lucky Penny was 26 year old DC Air National Guard lieutenant stationed at
Andrews Air Force Base in Maryland.
Jolted by or just see she aborted.
The methodical checklist climbed in,
ignited the engines and scream for ground crew to pull the wheel chocks within
minutes.
The petite blonde was piloting the [inaudible] fighter jet screeching at top
speed through the crystal blue sky with your commander.
Colonel Mark Says Seville piloting his own jet on our wing.
The date was September 11 2001 both the twin towers and the Pentagon had just
been hit.
There was a fourth passenger jet commandeered by Islamic terrorists targeting
the United States capitol and the White House.
Obviously Heather knew there was no chance that any of the men,
women and children on board United Airlines seven 57 passenger jet,
she was intent on their septic would survive and an improbable twist of fate.
There was a good chance that Heather penny's own father could be the captain on
the United Flight 93 which she was disturbed,
determined to destroy.
It sounds cold hearted.
I mean that was my daddy.
Penny said in an interview afterwards,
I couldn't think about it.
I had a job to do.
She said later to her mom,
we don't train to bring down airliners.
Colonel Sasa.
Bill said,
describing the gut wrenching,
unthinkable act.
He and Heather Penny we're about to commit training would have been useless in
any case.
Neither of their jets was armed.
No one had anticipated the need to have fully armed fighter jets at the ready to
protect against an aerial attack originating from within the United States.
I'm going to go for the cockpit.
Sasa Bill said,
I'll take the tail.
Penny replied,
without hesitation.
I genuinely believe that this was going to be the last time I took off.
She said,
now a single mom with two girls.
I had already given myself up knowing what my duty was.
She was fully committed to ramming or jet into the passenger plane to bring it
down.
As fate would have it,
her father,
Colonel John Penny,
was not piloting United 93 that morning.
It was as good friend Jason Doll with Jason on the plane.
It would have been an additional level of grief.
Jon Penny said later,
but lieutenant penny and Colonel Sas Advil never had to execute their kamikaze
mission.
Let's roll.
Said 32 year old Todd Beamer,
a passenger on the hijacked fat flight.
Those were the last words of the soon to be father ending his conversation with
telephone,
switchboard operator,
Lisa Jefferson,
whom he had been relaying information to for the last 13 minutes of the
hijacking.
They had just finished reciting the Lord's Prayer and Psalms 23 together though
I walk through the Valley of the shadow of death,
I fear no evil,
evil for thou art with me,
thy Rod and thy staff,
they comfort me.
Beamer and the other passengers stormed the hijackers.
Jeremy Glick is a six foot judo champion.
Mark Bingham was a rugby player.
Tom Burnett had been a college quarterback.
Louis Knack was a weight lifter.
William Cashman,
a former paratrooper.
The cockpit recorder captures the sound of food carts ramming the cockpit door
and the cries of terrorist screaming at one another to hold the door closed.
The door burst open.
Let's get them is heard on the recording.
As passengers overwhelmed the terrorists,
they were the true heroes.
Heather Penny says these were average everyday Americans who gave their lives to
save countless more.
The selflessness reminds us that we're a part of something greater than
ourselves,
that there are things in this world more important than ourselves.
Today there's a memorial and the green pastures in southwestern Pennsylvania and
the White House in the United States.
Capitol stands spared from the destruction.
This is the power of the tribe,
trigger to life risking violence,
gangs,
wars,
racism,
or it's ugly,
dark side.
But this bit of neural circuitry is very much a part of what makes us human.
They can unleash the best in human nature,
set the sacrifice for others.
It is the trigger of heroism.
And as the monument now standing in the fields of Pennsylvania reminds us,
it's a vital part of every one of us.
So we have these circuits for reason.
I can't,
in the interest of time,
I have to come to a close.
Um,
I,
uh,
other important points that I would like to make is that stress is important.
Knowing the circuits as important because you can control it,
but understanding that stress changes the threshold.
If you're in a stressful environment,
um,
you're more likely to have these trip same as the military putting its defense
mechanism,
not on high alert.
If you grow up in a bad part of Palo Alto or Baltimore,
you're going to wire the brain so that you have a hair trigger because you can't
afford to be victimized.
Um,
and
I don't want to give away the book,
but I will.
Um,
I reacted that way in Barcelona because we were under intense stress.
That was the second time we were robbed and my Amygdala had learned that and
didn't talk to my cortex about it,
but it wasn't going to happen again.
The second point I'd like to make is that this mechanism threat detection
mechanism is controlled by the cerebral cortex.
And there are people who are completely nonviolent.
I interviewed them.
Um,
James,
for example,
who will kill nothing and,
uh,
no living animal.
And um,
so it is possible to have cortical control over this,
this circuitry.
I spoke to a teal,
a seal team,
six member told him what I did in Barcelona.
He said,
yeah,
I never would have done that.
You know,
here's the guy who could take out a pickpocket with judo chop,
you know,
doing a selfie and he wouldn't have done it.
And they train so that they,
that they,
um,
that they can control with cortical control,
these defensive behaviors.
Um,
and the other thing I wish I had time to talk about is gender.
The most important factor in aggression as gender.
94% of all,
um,
uh,
criminals and prison for violent crime are male.
Um,
but 94% of the people who have been given awards for heroism by the Carnegie
Foundation,
our mail,
a quarter of those died instantly giving their life often for a stranger to come
to their aid.
Um,
so gender is very important.
The neurosurgeon science of that is very interesting.
Men and women face different threats.
Their threat detection wiring is different.
I wish I could go into that.
MMM.
Let's see.
Um,
yeah,
I'll just end on one thing that it has been known for some time that stimulating
the hypothalamic attack region in animals and do in addition to inducing
aggression can induce copulation.
So,
you know,
through his,
through literature and psychology,
there's always this connection between sex and violence.
Now,
what we never knew is that if you stimulate this hypothalamic region,
are you stimulating nerve fibers that are just passing by your electrode in the
neurons or somewhere else in the brain?
Well,
it turns out recent work by David Anderson,
his colleagues at Caltech,
I'm using the new methods off to genetics that they found that they stimulate
neurons in the hypothalamic region,
the same neurons control copulation and aggression.
And they use a,
uh,
a laser fiber optic laser to stimulate these neurons and they can switch the
flip of a switch,
make this mouse go from meeting to fighting.
Um,
so that's interesting.
So in conclusion,
I want to say that,
um,
you know,
understanding is the first step in controlling anything.
So I hope that people can understand,
um,
that we all have the circuitry how it works,
that it's amazingly,
uh,
intricate and elaborate circuit.
I hope that people can benefit from understanding how it can misfire and that we
do need better ways to,
to control aggression.
Uh,
and particularly these days when we have so much aggression,
that is,
you know,
the police are always looking for a motive.
I understand what they say when looking for a motive,
but there is no motive.
It's a rage induced,
uh,
violence.
And that's what I hope that we can begin to understand by getting a neuroscience
perspective to go along with the perspective of psychology and behavior.
So that's it for why we snap.
Thank you.
Now for something completely different,
I have to go to my second talk.
I'll tell you that either of these talks is over an hour and the Q and a is the
best part,
but we just don't have time.
So let's talk about the other brain.
Um,
throughout my career I've studied how neurons are wired together and
development,
how these change the strength of their synaptic connections through experience
and how we store memories.
But did you know that only 15% of the cells in your brain are neurons?
What are the other 85%?
Well,
they're called Gloria.
The word means glue.
And that's how they've been regarded as just packing material.
Gallia do fire electrical impulses.
And so they're considered the cellular domestic servants of neurons.
They clean up after neurons or he moved neurotransmitters and maintain the ionic
balance.
They certainly respond to injury and disease.
But in recent years,
neuroscientists have come to realize that these cells do far more than anyone
expected.
Excuse me,
I'm trying to stay on time.
These cells do far more than anyone ever expected.
In fact,
they're involved.
Glee are involved in every aspect of brain function in health and disease.
And they're overturning our central assumption about how the brain works.
So this is what I call the other brain.
It's an exciting new frontier.
It was science.
It's only now being explored.
So I want to describe to you the major kinds of glial cells tell you some of the
things they do.
I'm going to have to skip a lot of things.
They do,
um,
hit the high points and,
some of this works from my lab,
uh,
but most of it comes from discoveries from around the world.
And,
uh,
I'm speaking here today in a personal capacity and not representing in an
official way the NIH at all.
Uh,
but first let's trace back to the roots and the story and try to understand how
we could have overlooked half the brain,
especially brain scientists.
So this is the object of our fascination.
You know,
all our thoughts,
our intellect or emotions,
our compassion,
hate reasoning,
perceptions,
creativity,
music,
art,
everything comes out of this bodily organ,
our unconscious automatic responses or respiration control,
temperature,
temperature control,
um,
kinds of things.
I was just talking about threat detection,
our personality and our identity.
Um,
our,
our memories,
our cycles of sleep,
all of this comes from two and a half pounds of flesh that can think you have to
look at it.
We don't have an idea how it does any of those things.
And the reason is,
is that the working parts of the brain are so concentrated and you my new,
they're invisible to the human eye.
Yet our fundamental idea about how the brain works,
it hasn't changed in a hundred years.
We're so accustomed to this analogy of the brain working as electronic circuit
that is difficult for us to think that it might operate in any other way.
But it could.
And it's hard for us to realize that when this electric circuit analogy was
proposed,
it was seen as revolutionary and controversial.
So our understanding of how the brain works is based on the Italian
neuroscientist,
a Golgi who developed a staining method allowed us for the first time to see
neurons.
And you imagine their excitement when they look these exquisite cells,
unlike anything else in the body.
Ramonica hall looking at the same tissue,
using the same method method,
saw something entirely different goals.
You saw that neurons are connected into a hydraulic network.
Hydraulics was the most advanced science of the day.
That's why probably we think of the brain working like in computer today cause
that's the most advanced science.
But he saw it is hydraulics.
All of these pathways are hooked together.
But,
um,
[inaudible] was,
was an artist before he was a scientist and he had an ability to deter,
to determine function from form and um,
looking at the same material.
He had a sudden insight that,
um,
neurons,
we're not connected together,
that they,
each one was separate and each neuron was separated by golf,
a separation,
which he called the synapse.
Andy saw logic.
That's what these arrows are.
He realized that the neurons are polarized.
That information passes one way through neurons in,
through the dendrites and out through the axons.
So all of our ideas about how the brain work is based on this idea,
the neuron doctrine.
And that is that,
um,
communication and information processing in the brain takes place by electrical
signals flowing through neuron's,
communicating across synapses.
But in the last few years,
scientists become started to realize that this assumption is not entirely
correct.
Now,
the hall made these insightful discoveries with the simple tools.
Razorblades simple microscopes here he has working in this kitchen.
Uh,
so it's amazing.
You can't even see a synapse with a light microscope is smaller than you can see
today.
We use the most advanced electron microscopy.
Hi super computers.
This is from Mark Ellis,
mens lab and UC San Diego.
In order to study to understand her own structure,
here's the front,
his lab one neuron,
one neuron can have up to a hundred thousand synapses.
That's what these little spines are on these dendrites.
Your brain and spinal cord are comprised of a hundred billion neurons.
I'll have to be connected.
Correct.
Um,
but you know,
this is not a vacuum about our space over here except in our thinking.
So let's look at what the tissue really looks like.
Again,
from Mark Ellis Mens lab.
What we're doing now is going into the brain of a rat,
a electron microscope level,
peeling away a layer at a time.
Here's a blood vessel.
There was a nucleus.
Here are the axons going by the point is only 15% of what you're seeing are
neurons.
And at this magnification you can't even see synapses.
There's gotta be enormous communication going on that were uh,
among these cells that is non snap Dick and non Ronel.
Uh,
and look at the intricate circuitry and you're talking about,
and I think you can appreciate but Kahala achieved.
Now as you zoomed back,
you see that this is only a thin section.
There's only six layers thick of this mouse brain.
So neurons are great.
They have these elaborate cell bodies,
they form these networks.
But so to glean as you go up the evolutionary tree from lower animals to higher,
you get more glioma per neuron.
The higher you go up on their level of evolutionary tree,
if you raise that animal and they're enriched environment,
you will get more glare.
The brain gets thicker is because you're getting more Gloria.
And if that interest you,
uh,
when Marian diamond here at UC Berkeley looked at the brain of Al Albert
Einstein to try and understand why he was so intelligent,
she couldn't find any difference in his neurons.
But what she found is,
is that,
um,
he had more Glam,
more Glio,
uh,
in the parts of the brain of all the imagination.
So that's just an observation.
It doesn't prove anything,
but it really intrigued people that Gallia might be doing more than we think.
So physiologists,
how did,
how did we miss half the brain?
What we use the wrong tools.
Physiologists,
um,
use tools to study electrical signals,
but Glio don't communicate using electricity.
So let me invite you into my lab and I'll show you how physiologists study the
brain.
The first thing we do is we just checked out the part we want.
This is the HIPPA campus of a rat.
Then we slice it very thin,
400 microns thick in this case so that we can keep this tissue alive.
Then we,
we
put this brain slice into uh,
uh,
the Faraday cage cause we have to exclude all the electrical interference in our
modern environment.
We use amplifiers and stimulators so that we can record the weak signals and
neurons and synapses.
Here I'm studying something called LTP where the synapse gets strengthened
during a memory.
Um,
the tissue is kept alive and artificial,
cerebral spinal fluid,
warmed auctioneer oxygenated.
And then we use these electrodes to stimulate and record the electrical
activity.
The point is all of this is useless because Gloria don't communicate with
electricity.
So what broke it open?
What broken open.
The other brain was kids playing video games because playing video games drove
the development of faster computers,
color monitors,
better video cameras.
So scientists graft or all that technology under the microscope.
In the past,
we just use formaldehyde.
Dick's,
the tissue,
stained it and looked at dead tissue.
But now with a video camera on the microscope,
we could look at living tissue and new dyes were developed that work like this,
a glow stick where when two compounds get next to create light,
this led to something called calcium imaging.
We're dyes were developed that calcium,
when calcium was added glowed.
Why was that important?
Because when neurons fire calcium ions come in.
So this would allow us to put a dye in brain tissue and watch neurons fire
electrical activity,
uh,
and use a microscope instead of using a electrical recording.
And it was so exciting when we first did this to see neurons firing,
but it exposed the other brains.
So here is,
um,
the textbook view of the,
of the Neuron synapses always leaves out this part.
Um,
it's really the park comprised of astrocytes.
We can find out what these cells are doing by using calcium imaging.
Um,
and as I'll show you here,
we put a calcium dye in with astrocytes.
Pseudo color sold more calcium is bright red.
Watch what's happening.
These cells are communicating
and they're not using electricity.
They're communicating with waves of calcium.
And watch this.
When I stimulate the neurons here,
it'll look like lightning bolts.
They're the astrocytes responded.
So now we have nonelectric communication going through brain cells,
not neurons responding to electrical activity in neurons.
No synapses all outside the neuron doctrine.
Why are they doing this?
How are they doing this?
So,
um,
quickly discovered how they're doing this and you can participate in the same
way.
Cause the Peter Guthrie along me,
this image of which was this experiment in which they did an experiment to test
one ideas.
Calcium might just go through the cell membrane through gap junctions,
which are kinds of channels between cells.
And that's how calcium waves go through tissue.
So to prove that they made a firebreak,
so they just scratched off the cells here and culture started a calcium wave
here.
And if this is the way it worked,
then the signaling should stop at the firebreak.
So now you can see the same way they did the first time they did their
experiment.
What happened?
Okay.
Glial cells communicate by broadcasting signals.
They don't have to be touching.
Those signals are neurotransmitters.
That quickly,
it turned out that glial cells,
astrocytes have the same neurotransmitter receptors that neurons have to
communicate it,
synapsis and the releasing the same neural transmitters.
That means that they can communicate,
but they can also interact with signaling.
Uh,
that's caring going on with neurons and synapsis.
So,
uh,
we understand that neuronal communication via the neuron doctrine takes place by
neurotransmitter's going from presynaptic to the post synaptic membrane.
Of course,
there's never anything else shown,
but let's take a look at here at,
and these are actual glial cells.
Astrocytes,
when the neurotransmitter is released,
it definitely signals to the other cell,
but it's also picked up by the astrocytes,
the astrocyte and turn releases neurotransmitters that can regulate it can
augment or,
or inhibit synaptic transmission.
So astrocytes can control the strength of the synapse and because they can
signal among each other without electricity,
they can send that signal to a different part of the brain releases a signaling
compounds and neurotransmitters to control a synapse at a different part of the
brain that's not wired to this part through a nonelectric mechanism of
communication through non neurons.
That's what I call the other brain.
And so this I think is so fascinating.
Here's another picture.
I just love watching these cells communicating.
Okay,
so we're a hundred years behind understanding Gallia again from Mark Ellis mens
lab.
We don't know the basic things about their morphology,
their really complicated.
They fill all the space between and interact with the synapsis.
And what was recently discovered,
a big surprise is that they've formed non overlapping domains.
So they divide up the cerebral cortex and to separate domains.
We don't know why,
but it seems that astrocytes may impose a higher level of structure on
information processing in the brain.
Um,
you can look at a neuron from a rat and it's identical to a neuron in,
in a human,
not true for astrocytes.
Human astrocytes are unique.
They're even different from primate.
Astrocytes,
they're huge.
One human astrocyte can encompass 2 million synapses and an interesting
experiment by Nedergaard and Goldman.
They transplanted human astrocytes and the mice and it made these mice
brilliant.
They ran,
they ran,
um,
mazes quicker and the synapses,
uh,
and much easier.
Um,
moving on to other things.
Astrocytes do.
Astrocytes are associated with blood vessels.
I told you they take neurotransmitter's,
they'd dump the waste from,
from synapses and neurons into the bloodstream.
They also take the nutrients out of the bloodstream and deliver them to the
neurons.
Look at this intricate structure.
If you could see they're interacting with synopsis,
but this also involves astrocytes and all kinds of vascular disorders.
Astrocytes also control blood flow.
This is from Eric Newman's lab.
Here's a blood vessel in the retina.
Here's an astrocyte.
And he stimulated the neurons to fire by shining a light.
You'll see that here with the yellow dot.
And look what happens to the blood vessel.
Okay.
Astrocytes control the local swelling and constriction of blood vessels in the
brain.
So in response to neural activity,
you may be familiar with Fmr Rye,
which is used to image activity in the brain that's based on local blood flow.
It doesn't sense neural activity directly.
It's sensing oxygenated hemoglobin and the astrocytes are controlling that lug,
local blood flow.
Neuro degenerative diseases overlooked Glioma.
And now we know they're involved in all kinds of disorders.
Als,
Parkinson's,
epilepsy at the time to go into it.
Brain cancer has almost nothing to do with neurons cause neurons don't divide.
But,
uh,
and counselors,
runaway cell division,
but,
um,
new,
research,
uh,
directing,
developing new drugs that can target these brain cells is leading to new
therapies to treat brain cancer.
Here.
This one's coming right in on the cancer better than surgery.
Um,
this was a surprise.
Astrocytes and glial involved a psychiatric illnesses.
Schizophrenia,
bipolar,
depression are all associated with changes in astrocytes and other Gleevec.
We understand these are all disorders of synaptic transmission and we treat them
with SSRS and other drugs to control synaptic transmission.
Well,
what's the cell that does this?
And the brain.
Normally astrocytes.
So astrocytes can be the cause or,
or be involved in number of psychiatric conditions because they stabilize the
environment.
They release neurotransmitters and growth factors and whatnot.
In fact,
you know,
um,
the discoveries are often made and then forgotten the electroshock therapy
that's used for treating depression.
Still the most effective treatment for depression that can't be treated in other
ways.
Where did that crazy idea come from?
Of shocking a person's brain and curing them of schizophrenia or depression came
from a lot of slough.
Medina,
who,
uh,
in the 1930s was a pathologist and he noticed people who died of schizophrenia
and depression had fewer astrocytes in their brain and people who died of
epilepsy had too many.
So he just said,
oh,
these disorders are caused by an imbalance of epilepsy and bounce of astrocytes.
So he induced to seizure to try to make more astrocytes and cure schizophrenia
and depression.
And,
and we don't know that that's how it works,
but considering all of the growth factors and functions that ashtrays carry out
there certainly likely to be part of it.
And New drugs can be treated to that.
There are four kinds of glass so far I've only talked about astrocytes.
The brain has its own immune cell isolated from the bloodstream by the blood
brain barrier and these are called Microglia.
And in these experiments by the gun lab,
um,
engineered a mouse genetically so that the Microglia fluoresce green.
Then you put a window in the cranium and stuck the mouse's head under the
microscope and looked into the brain and then could see what these microglia are
doing.
Um,
and then he,
in addition,
he created an injury with a laser beam.
And here's what they found.
These cells were dynamic.
They were moving.
Um,
and when you create an injury,
they were like marines descending on this.
It could be a bacteria or a virus or an injury to,
uh,
deal with this.
So this is going on in your brain right now.
Those little fingers are going around to checking your synapsis for damage and
whatnot.
Um,
glee are involved in infectious disease.
Good examples.
HIV doesn't even affect neurons yet.
There's a dementia in HIV.
Um,
but it does affect a astrocytes in Alzheimer's.
ever since Alzheimer's described the disorder,
he noticed microglia involved.
And also these plaques,
well,
these amyloid plaques are surrounded by Microglia,
but we now can see that they're eating.
The amyloid is involved in Alzheimer's and this was thought to be just a
reaction to pathology,
but now you realize,
well,
what if they don't carry out this function normally throughout life that could
cause Alzheimer's.
In fact,
new research is showing that microglia becomes senescent ahead of the neuronal
dysfunction in the brain.
It considering,
indicating in a role of Microglia and initiating Alzheimer's.
Chronic pain is also involves and morphing addiction also involves microglia.
Um,
you know,
chronic pain is the pain that won't go away after your injury heals.
Um,
you have an injury to the peripheral nerve.
Turns out that that the microglia inside the spinal cord become reactive.
They change,
they start to release,
uh,
substances like cytokines and uh,
and other factors that make neurons excitable.
So you're paying neurons are firing because the microglia stimulating them that,
um,
and here,
uh,
you can see the microglia releasing these vesicles full of all of these kinds
of,
uh,
substances that excite neurons cause pain.
This is also important and opiate addiction because opiates decreased neural
activity turns out microglia release substances to bring it back to normal and
you ratchet up so that you now need more and more and more.
And Morphine,
morphine.
And if you block the morphine,
then you have this terrible rebound.
So microglia are involved in that.
They're also an,
uh,
another interesting aspect of Microglia is that many people will take marijuana
to control pain and inflammation.
Uh,
they don't want the cognitive side effects.
It turns out that the receptor that is an important in inflammation and pain is
on Microglia,
not under Ron's is called a CB two receptor and this is leading to new drugs
that can treat pain and not evolve and not have the cognitive effects.
Now I want to end with Mylan forming cells.
These cells form electrical installation on the axons.
We've cut an Axon here and half nerve fiber and it's wrapped around this
membrane of installation like electrical tape,
Schwann cells,
spindle shaped cells do that and your arms and trunk,
the peripheral nervous system and these octopus,
she sales do this in the central nervous system,
a very different sell and I want to show you the experiment that got me into
Neuroglia interactions and this looks a little old because this is an old
technology,
but I put dear Jean neurons,
which are sensory neurons,
the ones that sense pain and those and touch in culture.
There's big round circles here.
And then I had in Schwann cells,
I stimulated the neurons to fire.
I used that calcium die and certainly the neurons responded.
But then to my surprise,
the Schwann cells did no synapsis again.
Why is this happening?
How does it happen?
What are the consequences?
That's what got me interested.
Then I moved into the central nervous system because oligodendrocytes or the
Myelin forming cells in the central nervous system cells,
unlike any other cell in the body,
can ramp up to a hundred layers of membrane around an axon through 50 different
processes simultaneously.
Could they be involved in cognitive function?
So myelinating glio changed the way impulses are transmitted.
They accelerate the speed of transmission by constraining impulses to be
generated only at these bears patches every millimeter or so along the Axon.
So they act like repeaters.
So vertebrates are the only animals that have myelin and the conduction velocity
is 50 times faster.
Half the brain is composed of white matter.
The gray matter is what you hear about.
That's where the neurons aren't dendright.
But the white matter is all bundles of these axons.
And by and large people ignored white matter.
Um,
because the interesting stuff was going on up here,
according to the Neuron doctrine,
the human brain,
half of it is white matter more than any other animal,
mouse brains,
only 10%,
because we have so many connections.
Um,
and we can see these here with imaging DTI.
so I'm going to show you here what white matter it looks like.
I showed you a similar images of gray matter.
Uh,
this is again serial electron microscopy.
I need to make the point that the structure of Myelin is sub microscopic.
You can't see it with light microscope.
See and need electron microscopy.
So we go through,
we look,
this is happens to be optic nerve.
Here's the capillary axons.
When we find a note of Ron VA,
we can trace it,
but that in the computer,
this is only one half a micron distance.
Um,
and then we can reconstruct the structure of the note of Ron Va.
This is understood that Myelin is important and d myelinating disorders like
multiple sclerosis.
Cause if you have a conduction block conduction failure,
you're going to have a functional failure.
But I wondered could Myelin be involved in learning?
And here's the evidence.
Here's what intrigued me,
that imaging began to show that all kinds of neurological diseases had changes
in white matter.
This is just brain imaging,
things like dyslexia,
autism,
Stuttering,
psychiatric disorders,
associated with changes in white matter is these are synaptic disorders and
differences in cognitive ability associated with white matter differences.
If you're good at music or bad at music,
if you're good at arithmetic or bad,
there were differences in white matter structure can.
Now we're not talking about dysfunction,
we're talking about normal ranges of function.
So another important thing to know about white matter and then Myelin is that
it's not done at birth.
It takes place throughout life.
Uh,
and the show here creasing colors of blue and the human brain from the back of
the Cortex to the front.
Prefrontal cortex is not myelinated until you're early twenties.
That's also why the prefrontal cortex judgment,
um,
higher exempt level executive function can't really take place until the early
twenties.
That's when we get legal responsibility.
But the question is why,
if it was just installation,
why wasn't that done?
When you were born,
why do we see Myelin taking place over childhood and adolescence where we
understand experience sculpts and guides the connections in the brain.
So this led to a theory that a Mylan could be plastic and involved in learning.
And I think,
um,
this was a head scratcher but he'd probably be really obvious to you working in
the Internet.
Um,
and this is what we're calling activity dependent Myelin.
Myelin is function is to regulate conduction velocity,
speed,
impulse conduction.
We'd like to think of the human brain is the most complicated network in the
universe.
And to do any kind of cognitive function,
you need to send information from one relay point to another to another,
you know,
in order to carry out this,
I don't know about the Internet,
but I know transportation,
the most important thing is when I get to my relay point,
you know,
if I'm flying to San Francisco,
I need to get my connection in Chicago simultaneously with my connecting flight.
If I get there too late,
it doesn't work.
If I get there five hours early,
that's not optimal.
Has a lot of disadvantages.
We know that the conduction speed through all of these pathways in the brain
varies from a slow walk pace of a slow walk to the pace of a Ferrari.
How did all those speeds get set?
If they're not set right,
then you'll have dysfunction.
Um,
and so it seemed to me likely that maybe functional feedback experience could
change the myelination and then therefore promotes synchrony the spike time
arrival.
So that's how Mylan could be involved.
Uh,
studies and other labs have shown that after learning,
um,
there are changes in white matter.
Here's juggling.
It has been done with classroom learning,
video game learning,
every kind of learning you can think of.
But now we're completely unchartered waters and we've always been thinking of
the synapse.
But now if we're going to involve Myelin in learning,
there's so many questions.
This has to be,
uh,
not synaptic communication,
but action potentials.
How to myelinating glial sense activity in axons.
There are no synapsis.
How would it modify my Ireland?
Would it be important in information processing and learning and just how
plastic is mine?
Then people think of it as static.
So in my lab we do our studies in cell culture.
We have electrodes,
we put in sensory neurons here.
Then we put on a myelinated Glio oligodendrocytes.
We stimulate them and culture anyway we want and we can study the effects of
neural activity on myelination.
We can do gene analysis on the glial cells and see how they respond to
electrical firing.
We can block signals were like neurotransmitters and understand how this
communication is taking place.
We can do calcium imaging.
Here's an all ago on axons that are red.
And when I stimulate the axons,
the oligodendrocytes response,
no synapsis,
not neuron doctrine.
And if I put in botulinum toxin,
which blocks vesicle release and stimulate the neurons,
the oligodendrocytes still responded.
That tells us that in addition to vesicles releasing neurotransmitters,
they're not.
The secular means like channels that are releasing neurotransmitters,
all kinds of mechanism of communication,
activity dependent that we've ignored because we're so focused on the synapse,
our work has shown that electrical activity promotes the initiation of
myelination.
This means that electrically active axons are preferentially myelinate.
So as you're learning to play the piano,
those pathways become preferentially myelinated.
We've identified a number of the cellular mechanisms of signals involved,
uh,
over the years.
This is from our lab and other labs or finding new signals.
The whole point is that we're likely to find as many mechanisms of Myelin
plasticity is there are for synaptic plasticity has just that who are just
getting started.
And most recent work has,
uh,
Richardson's lab used a mouse genetically modified so that it couldn't form new
Myelin and trained it to run on this wheel missing rungs.
And it learned more slowly.
So myelin facilitated learning in this case.
So here's what the neuron doctrine left out.
Astrocytes look at tenders,
sites,
Schwann cells,
Microglia,
and all this communication rich communication going on among these cells.
All types of glio sense and respond to neural activity.
Glio communicate with each other.
And with neurons,
they regulate the neuronal brain.
They're central to psychiatric neurological disorders and Myelin speeds.
Impulse conduction may be very important as a new center of mechanism,
but learning to promote synchrony and optimal flow of information through
complex networks.
Um,
but it's important that,
um,
hm.
Okay.
I had some other things and I'm not sure why there is that,
um,
you know,
the neuron doctrine doesn't work without Glioma.
I don't think that the uglier work in different ways.
They work on a,
they broadcast signals and neurons communicate serially the communicate slowly.
Every movie I showed you was sped up,
but you know,
if glee,
I did the same thing,
there's neurons,
why would we have them?
So we have to look at gleaned through a different Lens.
Um,
and this offers new possibilities for new drugs and alternative treatments that
were directed towards school.
Yeah.
Um,
and if you want to know more,
this is the book and the I try to capture in this book was the excitement of
neuroscientists on the cusp of a new vision of the brain that completely
overturned a previous thinking.
And I wanted to capture that moment.
This happens in science all the time and every field.
And this is what's happening right now in brain science.
So I'd like to thank you very much for your attention.
We're going to take some questions,
we'll keep it going up
and as questions.
Meanwhile,
I'm going to ask a question.
So if I understood correctly,
um,
uh,
glial cells regulate functioning of the neuron parts of the brain.
Like for example,
when we see activity in the Fmi,
ry,
uh,
that's sort of the Leah or astrocyte specifically regulating like what parts get
activated,
is that correct?
That's correct.
So there is a glare or sensing neural activity and the responding to it and
they're modulating neural activity and they're modulating a also local blood
flow.
So,
you know,
Ephemera is interesting,
we take it for granted that you can look at you,
you can put,
give someone a cognitive task and look in the brain and see what part of the
brain,
what circuitries involved.
But you realize we're doing that by looking at blood,
local blood flow and astrocytes are controlling that.
But that raises the bigger question.
What if that didn't happen?
So right now I've,
we're talking different parts of our brain are being activated and that means
that astrocytes are controlling local blood flow.
If that didn't happen,
what would happen to cognition?
The neurons wouldn't get enough glucose and uh,
they would build up too much potassium.
So,
uh,
you know,
beyond this importance and in imaging,
and it raises a really fundamental question that I think is really not explored
this,
you know,
how Glio and blood flow is actually controlling our cognition or allowing it to
take place.
Uh,
are we anywhere close to like learning how to regulate Leah?
So like how to regulate the regulation if we wanted to do that.
We are the three kinds of focus and learning and things like.
Exactly.
So we have to get new tools.
This is very hard.
Uh,
and uh,
there are new tools being developed.
I also have to say part of the reason we overlooked half of the brain is the
nature of how science works,
right?
If you worked on unimportant cells and,
uh,
you weren't likely to get grants,
your papers didn't get published in big journals.
Nobody heard about it.
People's careers were really stifled because they work on glial cells and now we
have that problem.
We understand that Gloria are important,
but if you work on snap Dick Transmission,
um,
as a neuro physiologist,
you're not necessarily eager to have that picture complicated,
bring in another cell,
whole other kind of technique.
And so the field is struggling right now to make advances to get new techniques
that everyone will accept.
Um,
and there is this enormous,
almost a conflict of interest,
right?
Because if you're studying snapped at transmission,
you don't want to understand,
you don't want to have to start studying my on Friday,
but a new tools need to be developed and people are working very hard to make
them.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I see.
Uh,
it's very interesting.
Talk about in the snap you said the seals actually to get trained not to react
like that,
make those snaps.
What,
so what kind of training they receive?
I'm very curious.
Well,
the navy works on these and he described some of the,
they had the exercise is to teach them to control these,
uh,
this aggressive responses.
So they have very specific programs.
I mean,
one was,
they called the,
uh,
who did,
they put a hood on them.
And then they take off the hood and there's all kinds of threats around them.
Um,
there might be a hostage situation or something and they have to analyze very
systematically what are the threats,
prioritize them.
In other words,
they rely on cognitive function to break down and the threats and respond not
just on a gut level.
At the same time you talk to these guys and also interviewed a lot of
fascinating people.
We have secret service,
but also sports figures.
They also rely on their gut.
I mean,
they'll walk into a building and Afghanistan and say,
you know,
this just doesn't feel right and they all leave and find out that there's,
and it blows up when they walk out the door.
And that's because your threat detection mechanism is fast.
I told you that's one reason and it's fast,
but it's also much more capable of handling norms,
amounts of information,
right?
We can hold eight digits in her mind at once.
That's pathetic in our consciousness.
Right?
That's why we can't do long division.
We can't,
it's not difficult,
but can't hold that intermediate answer long enough to do the next step.
Your unconscious brain is constantly crunching an enormous amount of data about
your internal state,
your external state.
That's how I was able to do that in Barcelona.
So what amazed me is that we all have this ability to constantly survey for
dangerous.
And so people do learn who worked at high levels,
uh,
performance do learn to trust their gut and how to develop that as well.
So it takes both athletes do the same thing.
I have some stories about athletes and avalanches and skiers and things where
they rely on the gut.
But think about the most complicated decisions we make in life.
We don't do rationally,
right?
Who to marry.
You know where to live.
You can't make a spreadsheet and come up to you,
rely on your gut.
And that's because there's too much information.
Too many unknowns.
Okay.
Operating processes like images and a experience is differently from the way we
process logical information or math.
Computer Science for example.
And I've notice a lot,
some Asian,
our readers can basically deliver a speech for hours without looking for any
note and also like a very genius like at Tesla and uh,
and Davinci rightly see that invention for example,
Tesla was able to see,
lay led,
the deed her a picture of DC generator before he actually did any detailed work.
And uh,
in the,
in the past few years I've been trying to kind of combine this can kind of
techniques and a charter pilot that in computer science for example,
why in our Das Jack to that unit in the architecture stuff,
I try to map that to a nursery information.
Like why walk through this?
I get a lot inspiration that we'd arrange of flowers and the trees,
everything.
Right?
So my question to four years,
how can you shed some light on how our brain works?
Uh,
in terms I'll re recording experience.
For example,
your experience with Barcelona is so Vivian,
right?
Jumped his GED car into the taxi costs you 176 euros to your faith from facts.
Right.
Is,
is so vivid.
It's so you were now forget about that,
right?
Versus some math formula or some computer science data structure,
it will be far more difficult to recall.
So how do you,
if we combined these two parts of bringing on work work together and what,
can you shed some light on?
Analyze scientific mechanisms?
It's a good question as you've combined a couple of questions.
So first,
in terms of what goes into memory memory is not about recording the past.
I mean,
do you want to remember that great parking place you had at target three years
ago?
I mean,
most of what we experienced during the day,
we forget.
Um,
and uh,
so what,
what you remember our experiences and they're likely to have significance for
the future survival value.
And so as you go to sleep at night,
you relive your experiences of the day.
And that's when,
uh,
short term memories get converted to longterm memories.
My labs done research on this as well.
Um,
and so things that are novel are likely to be important for the future.
you know,
if you,
if you have bad food at a restaurant,
you know,
you don't need to do it twice,
you're not going to eat that again.
So there's so emotion and we understand very much about the physiology,
about how that works.
Emotion is one of the things.
Novelty is one of the things that converts short term memory to long term
memory.
Your second question was about vision.
Human Being's vision is extremely important sense for human beings.
Um,
not true for nice and other animals.
and we have an amazing capacity.
You're right.
I mean,
I,
there,
there have been studies and I don't wanna give the wrong answer,
but you can look through a magazine that you've looked through a couple of years
ago and identify every picture.
Yeah,
I've seen that picture.
We don't,
you know,
and that's normal.
We have amazing capacity for visual memory.
That is because a third of our cerebral cortex is devoted.
Division is such an important process for us.
I interviewed somebody in the book who was a blind person who's congenitally
blind and she doesn't have pigment in her,
in her retina.
And so,
you know,
there's no question about it being,
um,
being,
uh,
you know,
malingering or something that put her in that we did put her in that from our
ion.
She can't see.
But a third of our cortex is sitting there with nothing to do.
So what happens is other senses get wired to the CORTEX.
She can,
um,
see pictures by putting her fingers over at page and she's probably picking up
on little thermal diff distance differences.
We could do this.
Maybe if we practice,
I mean,
we could all play the violin,
I suppose,
in theory,
but,
um,
she's using this enormous brainpower that has nothing to do normally devoted to
vision.
She can,
uh,
echolocate walking around.
She has tremendous synesthesia because there's the census get mixed.
She can,
uh,
here,
she can read five times faster than anyone else than a sighted person.
Uh,
and he just turns up to speed until it sounds like gibberish and it's no problem
for her to decode it because the brain power is devoted to it.
So it's true.
Vision is very important.
And we,
and,
and people who do have these remarkable abilities for memory,
one of the tricks,
they always use it to make an image,
you know,
and they make some concoct some image of it,
monkey sitting on a chair that reminds them of something else.
They create this big scene and then they just described the scene yet.
Uh,
so I just had a quick question then.
So what advances I guess or in imaging technology are going to be needed to kind
of really like continue to progress the study of glial cells?
Yeah.
Um,
well I'm working on some of my labs that allow me to look at Meyerland structure
in a living mouse without any dyes or genetic engineering.
I'm using new spectrum,
uh,
spectroscopy methods adapted to imaging.
Um,
I think there's a lot of development and imaging.
The two photon and the confocal imaging have been great help.
Fiber optic cameras have been a great help.
Really building cameras,
uh,
building microscopes that are miniature microscopes that can be put on the skull
and uh,
with connecting with a fiber optic lens into the brain.
And then we could see neurons firing.
So there's,
that's one area.
There's a lot of area because optogenetic stimulates neurons with light of being
able to direct laser beams so that you can not just stimulate,
you know,
a whole bunch of tissue,
but you can target individual cells.
Imagine that and,
and begin to decode this network because you can activate specific cells in any
sequence and you can record the responses with the camera to all of these,
this whole population,
things you could never do with an electrode or will not,
never,
never say never,
but very hard to do with electrodes.
Thank you.
Okay.
I wish we could have more time,
but they're going to wrap up.
Thank you all so much for coming and thanks to look,
they're legless fields.
This was really fascinating.
Thank you very much.